[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i am so excited to be here i've wanted
to come to js com budapest for
years and then the pandemic happened and
i finally made it 2022 so excited to be
here and it is definitely living up to
it's amazing reputation for sure i love
the atmosphere i got here at 11 30 last
night and
people were celebrating partying and i
thought it was a festival and it wasn't
this is just the life here and i love it
[Music]
the community this conference cares
deeply for community cares for inclusion
and the best thing about this conference
is it's about javascript it's jsconf but
it's about the community more than the
language so you'll hear talks about
mental health about people's workout
routines and then some code too so it's
a good balance my favorite kind of talks
are the ones that talk about you know
like taking things from various worlds
and connecting them together like making
a fusion out of them and i think that's
the stuff that really makes things most
interesting and i can really see that
here in budapest in jsconf it's really
cool
[Applause]
this is my first conference outside of
south africa so definitely my first js
conf the audience has been absolutely
incredible the feedback that i'm getting
is absolutely beautiful and the speakers
themselves my goodness i'm blown away by
all the different talks that i've seen
and the organizers are absolutely
incredible the audience here is really
supportive like if somebody comes up on
stage they tend to like applaud them
just for coming up on stage because that
in itself is so hard i love that because
there's a lot of first-time speakers and
people who benefit a lot from that so
it's a very inclusive and supportive
audience i love it
[Music]
i think the future of javascript is
bright i mean the present of javascript
is bright but the future is is really
nice
my favorite proposal is records and
tuples it's records and doubles are like
objects and arrays except that they're
immutable so you can add to them and
you'll get copies and they're very
efficient and everything i think they
will revolutionize javascript as much as
or even more than the you know the type
annotations proposal the javascript
feature that i'm really excited about
that's still in early stages i would say
is the typescript in javascript proposal
with types i love typescript i do a lot
of live coding and i can do it
confidently because of typescript
because it keeps me safe so if we bring
that safety to javascript that's amazing
i'm here for it
[Music]
i hope that i'll keep coming to this
conference for the next few years i will
come up with another talk that is not as
stressful as this one just to be here so
i will absolutely try my best to
be at jay's called budapest and
hopefully a few others as well in the
coming years
[Music]
you